as the taliban consolidates their
control of afghanistan they are selling
themselves as a new more moderate group
that will respect women's rights and not
retaliate against afghans who fought
against them
but those promises are being met with
skepticism big skepticism as many
afghans fled kabul airport trying to
board flights leaving the country the
u.s ambassador to the u.n that's linda
thomas greenfield joins us now to
discuss good to see you madam ambassador
what's your biggest concern right now
it's great to see you as well gail look
our biggest concern right now and our
major priority is working
around the clock to get
those people who need to get out of
afghanistan out we were able to get a
thousand out yesterday and we're moving
forward
uh rapidly to move others out of uh out
of danger
you know people are looking at it and
i'm sure you two were haunted by the
images that we're seeing why weren't
preparations made ahead of time and i
know hindsight is 20 20. i get that and
everybody that has no experience with
anything has an opinion but it does beg
the question why preparations weren't
made earlier to make sure that this
transition went a little better look at
this with the people literally hanging
on to the plane preparations weren't
made yeah
uh gail absolutely preparations were
made we did contingency planning but
none of us
can appreciate what happens when the end
of a civil war takes place and and the
uh victors uh enter the city but we were
prepared for this and we are working
around the clock to ensure that people
are are given
support to get out of the country i
heard a white house spokesperson say the
other day i wrote this down we've
received assurances from the taliban
that we will those words don't even seem
to go together to me when you hear them
in a sentence
how how what stock are you putting in
what the taliban is saying we have
changed we're encouraging women to join
the government there will be no uh
retaliation against any of the afghan
people who have worked with the us
how are you viewing that
you know we have to see what they do
we hear what they're saying
but it is their actions that really will
define how they address these issues
moving forward and we will be watching
very carefully what they do as it
relates to women and girls and
inclusiveness
what is the u.n doing right now to
protect girls in particular and women
the women are very afraid many of them
are in hiding
i i feel their fear
but the un announced very early that
they will remain on the ground they will
continue to support programs for women
and girls and we're all including myself
here in new york we're pushing
every single member of the u.n of the
security council to raise their voices
in unison to say to the taliban that it
is absolutely imperative that they
protect the rights of women and girls
madame ambassador it's tony decouple
we've seen pictures online of courageous
women good morning to you thank you for
being with us we've seen pictures of
courageous women in afghanistan
protesting the taliban's takeover some
at 6 30 in the morning walking to school
as though it's just another day and
nothing has changed obviously both those
activities do carry new risks this
morning what would you advise what does
the u.n advise to the women afghan of
afghanistan right now should they stay
inside watching weight or try to go
about their lives
you know i i have to leave that to
afghan women to decide for themselves
but personally i think they need to
make every attempt to go on with with
their lives knowing that
we in the international community will
be looking to ensure that they are
protected are you talking with
representatives in the region
are you in communication with that
uh secretary blinken has been on on a
almost hourly basis on the phone with
his counterpart
i am speaking uh daily with my
counterparts here in new york and we're
engaging actually in the security
council on afghanistan
you may have seen that we issued a very
strongly worded statement
that got unanimous support uh and and
that's an important statement unanimous
support in the security council calling
on the taliban to honor him humanitarian
programs to support human rights and
particularly the rights of women and
girls and to ensure that afghanistan
does not become a safe haven for for
terrorists
well we're all watching the world is
watching let's hope things improve and
that this situation works out
a little better than what we're seeing
so far do more than hope yeah we have to
do more than hope gail we really have to
pull out every tool that we have to
ensure that women and girls are safe in
this case thank you thank you madam
ambassador we'll be right back